embattled Congressman George Santos
admits he misstated his resume and now
he's changing the story of how he
financed his run for Congress Caitlin
Huey Burns has been looking for answers
on Capitol Hill and in his district on
New York's Long Island
for anyone that I have no clue what
you're talking about ma'am the New York
Republican Congressman submitted this
amended Finance report Tuesday that now
says he did not use his personal funds
to loan five hundred thousand dollars to
his campaign raising questions about
where the money came from can you tell
us about the source of the money in your
feces another person not answering
questions hi I'm Nancy marks Nancy marks
was Santos's campaign Treasurer and
signed off on the newest filings well
she filed all of his reports which means
she should have known whether they were
true or false when she filed them as the
treasurer and she had that legal
responsibility hi Nancy my name is
Caitlin Huey Burns I'm a correspondent
for CBS News Marx didn't return our
calls so earlier this week we showed up
at a meeting for a Long Island library
where she serves as a board member we
found her seat empty and community
members also searching for answers and
now she's sitting on the board of cookie
with taxpayer dollars and anti-market
surge in their unpaid voluntary
capacity on this board she also signed
off on Santos's expenses which revealed
an unusual spending pattern 37 charges
of
199.99 just one cent below the threshold
that requires an invoice or receipt the
quantity of transactions just under the
received threshold is unprecedented what
would be the legal exposure for the
congressman
there is pretty significant legal
exposure for a number of folks involved
in this scenario it is illegal to lie
about where you got your campaign money
and how you spent it back on Long Island
we tried Nancy marks one more time at
her home where she runs her business
the lights were on but no one came to
the door
and now if you can believe it there's
even more to this story just yesterday
in a new FEC filing the Santos campaign
appears to have replaced Nancy marks as
the treasurer we reached out to the
attorney for the individual named and he
said his client was approached about the
job but Gail he said he didn't want it
a lot of people seem to be heading for
the hills and Caitlyn something tells me
Nancy Marx don't want to talk to you but
nice try thank you we tried yeah I see
that thank you